if you were thinking of buying a station
wagon the Citroen c5 tur is probably not
the first thing that would spring to
mind but could it be a genuine
alternative to the leading cars in the
segment you Manuel Shaffer is keen to
find out
in no-one's of them he says the car he's
testing uses a two-liter diesel engine
with 133 kilowatts and 180 horsepower
and he can certainly feel that it really
moves the version he's testing is an
automatic with six gears allowing you to
just glide along with the traffic
without having to keep changing gears
that's much too shy the most so it's
ideal for those who do lots of driving
the c5 can move from zero to 100
kilometres an hour
in 9.7 seconds and has a top speed of
219
yeah the c5 is equipped with suit winds
hydroactive three-plus suspension which
automatically adjusts the right height
to suit the road surface but adjustments
can also be made by pressing this button
so Amano L can set it high or very low
or anywhere in between the c5 also is a
sports setting which gives you a more
dynamic suspension dunamis is when sport
mode is activated the c5 has a lot more
grip on corners and the driving
experience is definitely more fun the
exterior has sleek lines which give it
an elegant look made a little more
dynamic by the headlights but in profile
it still kept the typical stationwagon
shape it helped me hit my mono well has
decided to try out the backseat and as
he expected there's plenty of legroom
there's a hand width of space still left
and the front seat is slanted in here so
there's a comfortable amount of room for
your knees which in comte was passed
the the trunk offers nearly five hundred
thirty three litres of space up to the
ledge here where you can pull out the
cover but what emanuelle finds really
interesting is the hide rack of three
plus suspension which allows you to move
the rear axle up and down to make it
easier for loading and unloading cargo
I'm glad ability horribie - had popped
on zhehan I know dolls - laden this only
works when the car is at a standstill of
course as soon as you start the engine
the height is automatically adjusted to
match the front axle
I listen oh no you mind well thinks the
c5 is definitely a success the only
thing that disturbs him slightly is the
controls in the middle the steering
wheel turns but they all stay in the
same place which takes some getting used
to
one time a man while nearly trapped his
finger while turning the steering wheel
but otherwise he finds it an extremely
comfortable car to drive the suspension
irons away all the bumps in the road and
the seats are also really comfortable in
fact it's so comfortable he says you
might not want to drive it if you were
very tired as you could be asleep in no
time
prices for the c5 tour started just over
33,000 euros our test car which came
with the exclusive trim level and a 133
kilowatt diesel engine will cost you at
least 42 thousand euros
you